I remember coming to Sydney thirteen years ago.
The entryway from the north into
Sydney is through this great bridge.
It was built to a great engineering
standard but it still needs to be
monitored and looked at.
[Music]
What we've seen over the years is an
increase in volume of vehicles. The weight of
trucks towing lots of freight and what
we're trying to do is understand how the
bridge responds to different loading and
making sure that that bridge will be
able to accommodate those changes
To conditions and loading uses over time.
Rhodes Maritime Services came to us
and said how can we manage Sydney
Harbour Bridge? Currently we send
inspectors, he said, but it would be really
good to have some sensors or some sort of
technology to help us get an early
warning if some maintenance is needed. And
we ended up with the technology where we
could basically give the bridge oa voice.
The bridge could tell the asset manager
when the bridge needs attention. We have
this fiber-optic network going the
length of the bridge with 3200 sensors
underneath the bridge. As vehicles
travel over the bridge we're measuring
vibrations and then measuring the response
of the structure to those vibrations.
With so much traffic going over it and wind
and other things going on so to extract
some meaningful information we use
machine learning. It's a set of smart
algorithms, can take the raw data and
then tell you the performance of the
bridge. It's going to help understand the
ability of that asset to cope in
different conditions and really maximize
the productivity and efficiency. Really
brings together distributed sensors,
communication networking technologies,
smart algorithms and data visualization
suited to our customers needs.
The next steps for us at Data 61 is to work
with Cisco through innovation central
taking all of our learning from the Sydney
Harbour Bridge and packaging it up in a way
thats scalable, can be marketed to
different segments and can apply to
different sized structures through
Australia and the world.
[Music]
I see a connected world, an Internet of
Things world and the ability to
connect and understand our
infrastructure is going to be
Key to that. This technology will
help us do that.
[Music]